[Music]
[Music]
you've known for 24 hours that an
unregistered wizard set magical beasts
loose in New York yes where is this man
[Music]
so you gotta go with the case full of
monsters huh
he's Chavez first it's his fan - do you
know anything about the Wizarding
community in America
we don't let things loose hey mister
English guy I think your angers had
chickens you wiped his memory right the
Nomad what no magic they're not on
wizard sorry we call the muggles
I don't think I'm dreaming okay the way
I ain't got the brains to make this up
[Music]
something is stalking our city wreaking
destruction and then disappearing
without a trace which is live among us
we've lived in the shadows for too long
ask all of you who does this protect us
danger he senses Dania
this is related to Grindelwald attacks
in Europe this could mean war we got a
plan right guys that need our help
was that everything that came out of the
case
I would let another one done I refuse to
bow down any long
time is running out let's just command
The Wizarding World you thought you knew
is much larger than you imagined
history has many secrets
the official story is never the whole
story
look beyond the surface
and you will find another world running
parallel to our own a secret world where
magic is real in Romani
skinwalkers witch trials and the magical
congress of the united
to America
these aren't myths of the history of
America is more amazing than you could
ever imagine
everything you think you know is about
to change
magic in North America a series of
original stories by writer JK Rowling
read them exclusively at Pottermore
dot-com but prepare yourself for in
November you're invited to explore a
whole new era of the Wizarding World
[Music]
[Music]
it was like calm like a ghost I saw its
eyes shining white eyes and it does down
underground
the strange things going on all over the
city people behind this or not like you
and me
there's a hidden society it goes back
centuries yesterday wizard entered New
York with a case
[Music]
a case full of magical creatures
and unfortunately some have escaped teen
you brought men home
that's mr. Scamander he's lost something
I'm going to help him find we're gonna
recapture my creatures with what I get
hurt they're currently in alien terrain
surrounded by millions of the most
vicious creatures on the planet humans
[Music]
magical beasts i'll terrorize and no
matches when no matches are afraid they
attack contain this own little mean boar
it's on look why would I have to wear
something like this because your skull
is a scepter to breakage under immense
force
don't panic that there's absolutely
nothing to worry about
I want to be a wizard far across the
oceans and thousands of miles from the
legendary Hogwarts high atop Mount
Greylock hidden by forest cloud and
spell stands one of the greatest secrets
of the magical world ilver Morni School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry its enchanted
stone walls have stood strong through
the ages surviving fearsome battles
and weathering powerful storms
to become one of the Wizarding world's
greatest schools
if these walls could talk they would
tell you a tale of loyalty revenge
and a love that gave it life
and it all began with a young Irish girl
named is old Sayre and a unique stolen
mom
/ morning School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry an original story by writer JK
Rowling read it exclusively here on
Pottermore comm and this November
be prepared to explore a whole new era
of the Wizarding World
you
[Music]
my heroes are always people who feel
themselves to be set apart stigmatized
or offered that's at the heart of most
of all right it's certainly at the heart
of this movie
fantastic be somewhere to find them was
a textbook that Harry Potter used at
school while I was writing Potter I
became quite interested in Newt
Scamander so I knew quite a lot about
Newt
he's been traveling the world studying
magical creatures
because himself Imagi serologist first
trip to America yes
okay that fix needs creatures bled in
this magical case you open it up you can
go down it's an amazing space you feels
more at home with creatures than he does
with you big come on give me as far
nute walks into a society he doesn't
really understand this is granted do you
know anything about the Wizarding
community in America I know that you
have rather backward stores about
relations with no magic people they
don't mean to befriend them you can't
marry them which seems wildly of certain
marry him and then Jacob accidentally
opens in its case full of magical
creatures
hey mister English guy I think your egg
is hatching so new to gets broiled in
this adventure he starts a little bit
more like a beer
it's something that has implications for
the whole Wizarding World
[Music]
so excited to see the magical Wizarding
World continue all the world is brought
together new really exciting addition to
water juice Canada is a Hufflepuff
mcgaven is very special to me when you
think that the world of harry potter and
JK Rowling is got nothing more to offer
they come out with a brand new way to
just keep people excited I'm still
shaking decided to see new wizards and
witches that we don't know hummers how
you think it looks so wonderful know
what to expect
it's amazing I'm really excited to go
back into that University Square to go
to school watch it as a fun
[Music]
oh my god okay I had no work Oh
visualize faceless looks really exciting
I can't wait to see
[Music]
we are excited to see fantastic penis
fans we're gonna have to wait till
November to watch cool thing it was
opened just a smidge
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Jack hello I'm Charlie
and we are here today on the set of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
we're so excited because we're gonna be
joined by creators from all over the
world
oh look who I found
Bojan choice agua de Chivo smile Teemo
so set a deferment in magic hello tells
also ho y algo muy cool es que caminando
por esta skales con la veritable
spending our time today learning some
lovely little spells been a lot of fun
but now we're gonna throw over to some
of our Nomad friends swear muggles
aren't way to explain how the spells
work the first thing we learned is were
Paro so that's when you want to fix
something repair it when you see
something in a bad outfit you're like
Faro repair Oh ed a bottle bottle also
we learned obliviate yeah so does what
it like erases your method yes it's like
you're extracting a memories but also
yeah you got a little twisty like
pulling right now Bumi ate obliviate
[Music]
the last one we learned was Petrificus
Totalus
why is that so difficult for me to tell
it's like your warrior wizard pose
better if it cost Italian what's your
favorite spell reparo obliviate with it
very gusto da Luz
Petrificus Totalus a freewheel guitar
repair oh well thanks for watching
everyone and don't forget to leave your
favorite spells in the comments down
below and also don't forget to watch the
movie fantastic beasts and where to find
them coming out in November
ComEd see you there
[Music]
hello everyone you've just seen our
trailer and if you want to be a wizard
then you're in luck
I am Eddie Redmayne and I'm joined by my
co-stars Dan Fogler Katherine Waterston
and Alison sudol to invite you to a very
special live stream event so in select
theaters around the world you can
participate in a live Q&A with us and a
few other special guests as we learn
more about the new era of magic that
comes to life in New York in JK
Rowling's newest adventure to come to
screen fantastic beasts and where to
find them you'll also be the first to
see some exciting new footage it's bound
to be a magical event and we hope you
can join us see you then see you then
[Music]
you
you know for 24 hours that an
unregistered wizard set magical beasts
loose in New York so gotta go with the
case full of monsters huh
huge travels fine the magical community
is exposed I refused to bow down any
longer
could mean more containers I would add
another one doing
astha beasts and where to find them
rated pg-13 experienced at an IMAX
yesterday wizard entered New York with a
case full of magical creatures
and unfortunately some have escaped I
was hoping just a smidge
contain this on the lien war
[Music]
I wanna be a lizard fantastic beasts and
where to find them rated pg-13
experienced at an IMAX you're
interesting man let's just come and just
like your suitcase I think there's much
more to you than meets the eye
kicked out of Hogwarts for danger a
human life with a beasts
at one of your teachers arguing strongly
against your expulsion
I wonder what makes Albus Dumbledore so
fun of you mr. Scamander first trip to
America yes must get that fixed anything
edible in there I'm a nut knife any
livestock no welcome to New York
[Music]
no human could do this thing's capable
of
[Music]
[Music]
Lumos maxima Loomis Maxo
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday a wizard entered New York with
the case
[Music]
the case full of magical creatures
and unfortunately some have escaped
[Music]
it was open just a smidge mr. Scamander
[Music]
yesterday wizard entered New York with a
case full of magical creatures and
unfortunately some have escaped I was
open
justice [ __ ]
contain this on the lean war
[Music]
I wanna be a lizard rated pg-13
experience at an IMAX in theaters
November 18th
Lumos maxima
mysterious thing time you're a wizard
you're looking at the memories
you're interesting man mr. Scamander
it's getting closer
[Music]
this is a piece
whatever it is it must be stopped in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
you're learning about a part of magical
history that's talked about in the
Potter books that you never see I'm
getting a chance to tell that now
in the 1920s magic develop very
differently in America many wizards have
suppressed their magic to avoid being
persecuted by muggles they are therefore
living in hiding hear my words and heed
my warning
witches live among us they're looking to
expose wizards and witches if I succeed
we will be forces Taylor shadows forever
and we've both lived in the shadows for
too long the strange things going on all
over the city people behind this are not
like you and me
just look at the evidence because of
this tension the wizarding world has
seen a state of high alert at that time
but nuke comes to New York and one of
his creatures gets out he's immediately
arrested beasts are threat to giving
away that Wizards exist in pound that
case graves please you don't understand
nothing in those dangers will be the
judges of that graves is the or he
investigates anything detrimental to was
a kind so sitting a pack of dangerous
creatures Luke's here was just another
accident as that would tell you I wonder
what makes Albus Dumbledore so fun of
you
we don't really know who's good and
who's bad until all the chips have
fallen you know which of your creatures
was responsible missus commander look at
the marks no creature did this
this could mean exposure took me more we
got a plan right guys they need our help
this is new material
there are ways in which we connect to
the Potter books that I think people
will find surprising they think this is
related to Grendel world attacks in the
Europe they're talking about the first
time a wizard rose and threatened the
world order I saw the vision of immense
power
this was always where I was interested
in going
this is what I wanted to do
you
what I saw in there and film